ya son más de 1.200 muertos los muertos
por el seísmo ocurrido esta pasada
madrugada en la frontera entre Turquía y
Siria en cuyo epicentro ha sido a la
provincia de calamar marash unos pocos
kilómetros dentro de Turquía con la
frontera serie de hecho estos 1200
muertos no son todos en Turquía sí que
son la mayoría según ha explicado hace
unos pocos minutos erdogan son 900 en
Turquía pero son también 300 en Siria
que podrían ser muchos más porque el
país árabe tiene muchas más dificultades
al estar dividido y azotado por una
guerra que dura desde hace más de 11
años les mucho más difícil concretar los
números exactos por lo tanto se espera
que podrán ser muchos más después de
este por culpa de ese terremoto de 7,4
en la escala de richter uno de los
terremotos más grandes que ha azotado
Turquía que recuerda mucho a los turcos
a de ese terremoto en 1999 en izmita
unos pocos kilómetros de Estambul ese
terremoto de una magnitud parecida causó
la muerte de 17.000 personas no se
espera que este tenga
una tasa de mortalidad tan grande pero
sí que se esperan que sean muchos más
Los Muertos contando que hay miles de
personas ahora mismo bajo las runas
siendo rescatado por los equipos de
rescate de Turquía que de hecho ha
pedido ayuda internacional para poder
llevar a más personas a salir de la
runas y a poder escapar de la cárcel
ahora mismo la que se encuentra